some big news
you guys sold out the dire ceo live show
at the london palladium in just nine
minutes
and then the palladium called my team
and told us it was potentially one of
the fastest selling events they've ever
had
and then you called the palladium and
emailed the palladium and dm'd me and
you asked us for a second night in
london
and i heard you
so you're hearing it here first on the
first of december at 10 a.m
tickets for the dire ceo live night
number two are going on sale at
thediaryofseolive.com
you can add your name and email to the
website now and you'll be emailed first
with the link or just pop it in your
diary as a reminder if you missed out
last time i sincerely hope you managed
to get a ticket this time the 1st of
december at 10 a.m like i said last time
i'm going to do what i can to meet as
many of you as i possibly can at the
event it's a music-filled experience
with myself and the legendary house
gospel choir it is my favorite thing
that i do you'll hear things you'll feel
things and you'll have a great night i
hope to meet you there
and this is freaking genius i've taught
it to millions of people it's curing
people's anxiety there is nobody like
mel robbins there is nobody if i
hadn't done what i did that morning my
life would have gone in a totally
different direction i'd probably be
divorced i'd probably be an alcoholic my
family would be torn apart no idea what
i'd be doing for a living or where i
would be
i finally had the experience
of being in my body
and being safe and being okay
and i hadn't had that in a really long
time
um
so you asked me in the beginning
kind of
what is it that that created all of this
insight or this drive to figure it out
i think i just figured it out
you you just [ __ ] did it
[Music]
they call her the female tony robbins
but she's so much more than that
she's one of the most incredibly
vulnerable honest introspective
wise people i have ever met in my entire
life and she's written three
best-selling books that offer a very
simple solution to have a transformative
impact on your entire life i first found
out about mel robbins some seven years
ago when i watched a video of her
talking about how to motivate yourself
every single day and when my team told
me that she was coming to london for a
short trip i said we have to get her on
this podcast there is nobody like mel
robbins there is nobody i've never seen
mel robbins cry during an interview
before but in this podcast
it happens again we have an epiphany
mel removes her glasses she begins to
cry and it's an incredibly touching
moment i think for a lot of you this is
going to be the favorite podcast on this
channel that you've ever listened to
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
director ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
before we started recording i said a lot
of nice things about you just a few
seconds ago and um
i talked about how sort of introspective
you are how much you've achieved your
remarkable ability to speak about ideas
and things you've discovered in yourself
um you really are a standout individual
and so whenever i meet someone that i
consider to be a really standout
individual it always begs the question
to me having a small background in like
childhood psychology what is it what was
the cauldron in which mel was sculpted
that made you the person you are today
at the very start of your life
i
i guess that
i'm trying to think about like there's
no defining moment
because i had great parents
who did the best that they could with
what they were handed in terms of their
own childhoods and patterns and thinking
and
i grew up in a tiny little town where
nothing really happened
but one thing did happen and that was in
the fourth grade
i was uh at a family kind of ski trip
thing
and uh in the middle of the night i woke
up and one of the kids was on top of me
and
yeah like on top of me molesting me
we're going here like fast you asked
like what was the thing and this was
like the first thing that popped into
mind
and um
it was interesting because
i didn't remember the experience for a
very long time
i did not remember that this had
happened until i was in my late 20s
and
if you look at the spectrum of what can
happen to somebody in terms of sexual
abuse which unfortunately is very common
uh experience for people this was a very
mild experience like it wasn't anybody
that i knew it was a one-off it was
another kid so clearly something was
happening to this kid in their life it
wasn't scary it was confusing but i was
awoken
from a state of sleep
and i immediately felt and knew that
something was wrong
and it's my first experience in my life
of what psychologists called
disassociating i literally left my body
and i rolled over and i don't even
remember how it ended because i wasn't
in my body to be there and the very next
morning i'll never forget this um i hid
underneath the sheets because it was a
big bunk room and all the kids
left to go downstairs to get ready to go
skiing
and i remember waiting until i thought
it was quiet
i threw the comforter off i went down
these steep stairs i turned the corner
and there was my mom and she was cooking
breakfast with some of the other moms
and she turned around and she said
how'd you sleep
and i immediately
stephen wanted to tell her
and out of the corner of my eye
i saw the kid
and in that moment
split second child brain
i froze
and as much as i wanted to tell my mom
and i knew exactly what she do i mean
she grew up on a farm she had a spatula
in her hand she would have hit that kid
in the next week
but i didn't know what the kid was gonna
do
and in that moment i lied
and i said
fine
and the day went on and nothing happened
and i believe
whether it is a
30-year long struggle with anxiety
or a tendency to disassociate
or the fact that i was chronically lying
when i was younger in any moment when i
felt uncertain
i had no idea how that singular moment
set me on a
course that would last decades before i
realized that all of these patterns of
behavior that i was struggling with i
didn't know why i lied i didn't know why
i felt so uncomfortable if i couldn't
predict somebody's reaction i couldn't
understand why i would leave my body so
many times i couldn't understand why i
had very few memories from my childhood
it wasn't until i started to understand
human behavior
the way the brain learns patterns the
way that you need and can break patterns
and replace patterns and learn new
patterns that i began this journey that
i've been on for the past 10 years of
understanding my own breakdowns my own
heartaches my own struggles and sharing
what i'm learning with anybody who will
listen
how's that for an answer
yeah
did you ever tell anybody when did you
first tell someone about that incident
well i never told anybody because it's
like i forgot about it in that moment
like i just suppressed what had happened
and
there were lots of times in my life when
i was a teenager when i was in college
when i was in law school particularly in
law school because my anxiety
just came to a huge crescendo in law
school just completely out of control
with my thoughts with how i felt in my
body
i had not been diagnosed yet with
anxiety or anxiety disorder
and had not been medicated did not even
know anxiety was a thing so this would
have been
1992 through 1994.
and
um i didn't even remember it
and so i didn't even remember this
incident until
i was 28 years old and i was sitting in
like kind of one of these life
improvement seminars where you're in a
windowless conference room and
everyone's got a name tag on and there's
a person up front and this woman stands
up and she was talking about how she had
been molested when she was younger by a
babysitter that her parents hired and
the story went on how she had been in
therapy for a long time she was starting
to deal with the trauma of the
experience she had forgiven the
babysitter
she had forgiven her parents
but she could not forgive her sister
and the person leading the seminar kind
of looked at her and said why
what's wrong with your sister
and she said well i'm so angry
that this
babysitter
was choosing me
and while i'm in this room getting
abused my sister is out there watching
tv
and
when she said that i had an immediate
memory
and there was this triggering moment
where i
i was sitting in this windowless
conference room at the age of 28 but i
was physically in that bunk bed
because what i remembered in that moment
was oh my god
when i woke up in the middle of the
night with this kid on top of me i
looked to my right my younger brother
was sleeping in the bed right there
and my immediate thought was
i don't want this person to hurt him
and that's why i rolled over and stayed
quiet and so it was that
it was this woman telling the story
about her sister that triggered me to
remember it and as soon as i remembered
it oh my god i told my brother i told my
parents i you know i just started
talking about it i think that one of my
um one of the things that i'm grateful
for
is that i process things by talking
about it
once the dam is open baby like the
floodgates are coming like i just and
and so i tend to process things
by speaking about it and
for me it wasn't the
um incident itself
that created a lot of grief for me
because i know based on the work that
i've done as a crisis intervention
counselor working
with victims of domestic violence the
work i did as a criminal defense
attorney working for legal aid in new
york city and the amount of training
that we got
and also just the amount of work i've
done and studying that i've done on the
subject of psychology and human behavior
i know that when a kid is doing that to
another kid it's being done to them
so i even at the age of 28 i didn't even
have any anger toward the person that
did this to me
my anger was at myself
why didn't i remember this why why am i
so [ __ ] up why couldn't i have
remembered this like the
constant
self-bashing
that is the piece that um
i think has been the thing that i've
really struggled with
why am i so [ __ ] up yeah why am i so
[ __ ] up
you know there's um
there's this incredible thing about the
human design so when you think about
human beings
and you know as a as a parent so my
husband and i have three kids uh one's
23 another one's 21 and then our son is
16.
and as a young parent i would often
feel this incredible sense of awe
like it is remarkable
how many babies are born when you think
about how many things have to go right
you know what i mean in the design of a
human being
and there is so much elegance and beauty
and sophistication and genius to the
human design it's just
shocking
but there is one fundamental flaw
that screws up everybody
and that is that when you're a little
kid
and things happen to you
you do not have the life experience and
you do not have the support system
to be able to process what is happening
and it could be anything it could be
something as serious as homelessness and
poverty and systemic discrimination it
could be violence it could be abuse in
your home it could be addiction mental
illness it could be chaos in your
household it could be sexual abuse it
could just be a mother or a father who's
so freaking critical or who is
passive-aggressive so you wake up as a
kid and you have no idea
what you're going to wake up to
but when something goes wrong or
something happens to you as a kid you
don't have the life experience or the
support structure to basically go whoa
this situation is [ __ ] or these adults
somebody call the police like this is
not okay you don't get to talk to me
like like
no kid does that
the fundamental flaw in human design
is that when something happens to you as
a kid you don't say what's wrong with
that kid or what's wrong with my dad or
what's wrong with this situation
you say
what's wrong with me
we aim it back at ourselves
and then i think that you know this then
starts to build as a thinking pattern
that there must be something wrong with
me
that you aim everything that's happening
out there
back at yourself
and you did that
through your early early adulthood right
i think everybody does i really do i
think that that you know when you're um
growing up i believe that this happens
around the age of eight or nine or ten
that you know no human being is born and
hates themselves
we're actually wired for love we're
wired for connection um you know if you
look at a kid who's two or three or four
right and they see a mirror
they don't look at it and go ugh my
thighs are so fat like i can't you know
they look at the mirror and they put
their hands up and they twirl and they
kiss the mirror and they they love the
sight of themselves
and you and i don't remember this but we
loved the sight of ourselves too
and
what happens
because that's your natural state
that's your
wired state in my opinion you are wired
for self-love you're wired for
self-acceptance you are wired for
self-worth you are wired for
self-respect you're wired for resilience
i mean when you think about
a baby none of us remember this but you
will literally fall down 77 times an
hour and you'll just keep standing back
up so this resilience this sense of
empowerment the sense of really being
proud of yourself of loving yourself it
is part of your design your dna your
birthright but life happens
and it can happen two ways you know if
you grow up in a chaotic household you
start to absorb the message that
something's wrong
and so you go into modes of behavior to
protect yourself and these patterns of
behavior that you create to protect
yourself get locked in your brain
but for everybody so if you grew up in a
in a wonderful household like i did if
you grew up in a place that you were
very safe like i did
you still are going to experience some
kind of trauma because trauma is deeply
personal and trauma at its at its
simplest form is just a moment when your
nervous system
gets dysregulated a moment where your
whole body turns on an alarm
and when your whole body turns on an
alarm whether it's uh oh
there's the car pulling on the gravel
driveway
the person that drinks and comes home
and is abusive is pulling in
or uh oh mom's got that expression on
her face it better not say anything
it can be small moments big moments but
when your nervous system goes into a
state of alarm your brain kicks into
let's record everything in hyperspeed so
we can remember this so i can protect
you in the future and that pattern locks
and that's why so many adults continue
to stay trapped in patterns from their
childhood that they don't even remember
why they have them had like any of it
but for everybody so that's sort of like
if you grew up in a chaotic household
which i didn't but i think what happens
developmentally
is you know there's this moment when
we're in elementary school and none of
us remember it at least i don't remember
it but it happens to everybody
where one day you walk into elementary
school and you're like loving yourself
and you're happy as a clam and you're
just kind of walking up to whomever and
you like yourself
and you love yourself
so you'll go up to anybody you'll sit
with anybody in the cafeteria and then i
don't know
what the hell happens
but the next day
you walk into that cafeteria you got
your little hands on your tray and you
start scanning the room for where you're
going to sit and all of a sudden that
brain that is wired for self-love and
self-acceptance
flips
into the sorting hat from harry potter
and you all of a sudden see
the world
in
the places that you belong
and the places that you don't
and
that's how it begins
and your mind starts to tell you you
can't go there you don't look like those
kids those are the sports kids they're
gonna as a way to protect you
but the message that you start to get
from your own brain or from society at
large or from what's going on in your
household is that who you are is not
okay
when i was reading about your story
we're talking about education then in
schools um it seemed that you were quite
i don't know
disorientated in college
when you went to college and you were
struggling to figure out who you are and
that resulted in quite significant
procrastination and oh my god
yes
um so i you know i'm very open about the
fact that i struggled with anxiety for a
long time
and um
what's interesting about anxiety is that
you know i'm i'm now talking to you from
the perspective of being 53 years old
i was like really [ __ ] up and by
[ __ ] up i mean not that i was like
stealing cars or breaking laws or doing
anything like that
but i was not comfortable in my own body
and the way that i would describe it is
i think from that moment literally
that moment in fourth grade that i just
shared with you
it makes me really sad to think about
the fact that i was just a fourth grader
that had a traumatic experience
i didn't know
but my nervous system remembered
and so
any time
i went to bed
i woke up the next morning with the
sensation in my body that something was
wrong
and
any pattern of behavior or thinking
that you start to repeat
becomes a habit habits are just patterns
it's all that they are
and so i had a life experience because
of one incident where i would wake up
every single morning and feel like
something was wrong and i couldn't put
my finger on it
and the more that you wake up and think
something's wrong the more your brain is
going to find reasons why something
might be wrong
and so
i developed
this sort of chronic state of feeling
on alert
feeling
the sense that i got to be aware fight
or fly yes yes my you know in in
clinical terms my sympathetic nervous
system got switched on
and i had no idea how to turn it off
and if you don't know how to calm your
nervous system down to flip off the
sympathetic nervous system and flip on
the parasympathetic nervous system which
is your calm grounded resting nervous
system
you will forever struggle with focus
with being present
with the ability to think clearly and
make good decisions
you will constantly talk about the fact
that you feel anxious and that comes
from your nervous system
always being on edge and being in fight
or flight i didn't know any of this i
was just a nervous kid with a nervous
stomach every camp that i went to i got
sent home because i was too homesick oh
yeah i mean i was just i mean you know
how homesick you have to be for train
counselors to actually call your parents
and go uh we got a problem here she
can't stay here like she is
out of her mind
when you say out of your mind what are
the physical symptoms or verbal symptoms
of that oh my gosh um complete
disassociation so i would be at camp
like literally
sixth grade camp so at the end of sixth
grade year and i feel i feel bad for
little mel robbins i feel bad for her
because you know here's this this
experience sixth grade camp where the
entire school for four nights goes away
to a camp just the sixth grade it's
supposed to be the culmination of your
sixth grade year
and i am so
freaked out that something bad is going
to happen
that i of course escalate things in my
own mind i don't even feel like i'm at
camp i feel like i'm walking on a movie
set i don't feel like i'm on earth i
feel like i'm on a spaceship somewhere
looking down all the time
i uh feel like i might throw up because
my stomach is rattled because when
you're anxious and you can't focus your
thoughts you tend to not eat and so that
of course upsets your stomach it's not
that something bad's gonna happen it's
that you're screwing up the chemistry in
your stomach by not eating because
you're so nervous which only makes it
worse and as your mind is scrambling
thinking something bad is going to
happen and then your stomach is hurting
then you start to think oh my god i'm
going to throw up and then you start to
think well if i throw up something bad's
going to happen and then the kids are
going to laugh like it just becomes
this spiral train wreck and that is the
state that i lived in
and so um
you know you learn how to cope you it
becomes your new normal but that was
basically my life constantly feeling
like
something bad was going to happen
constantly feeling like i wasn't really
present constantly lying or fibbing
about how i felt or what i was thinking
because i didn't want people to judge me
it was awful and then you come through
college and you've got to make that
choice in life as to which direction
you're going to go in it's kind of it
seems quite choice i love the choice
yeah yeah well it is well how would you
define it
um panic panic yeah because i didn't
know what i wanted to do yeah because i
had only ever lived in survival mode
so did you did you not take a pause to
decide to sort of listen take a pause
who you were and what your your calling
was and take a pause when you have
anxiety
your whole mode of living is if i'm on
the move no one can catch me
if i am on the run i'm safe and so
what's interesting
is that i think the only time in my life
that i have actually
slowed down
was during the pandemic
does that sound familiar yeah of course
yeah you had no choice
yeah and
one of the hardest things
which became one of the greatest
realizations
is
truly coming face to face with myself
and realizing
that even though
i have done all this work to heal trauma
even though i have
uh
done extraordinary things in terms of my
own thinking patterns
that there was a level to which i was
still on the run
that i was darting off to a coffee shop
or darting off to target or darting off
to an airplane
and all of this racing around
kept me from having to truly stop and
stand with the woman in the mirror
and just be still and figure out well
what do i really
want
how do i really want to feel
you talk about the topic of distraction
and procrastination and it's rarely in
this context but it sounds like a form
of distraction distracting yourself from
the
from taking a moment to confront thyself
and
um
yeah to really ask some of those
questions which i guess if you're in a
fight or survival state
um the answer to some of those questions
might be
maybe illuminating to a vulnerable you
know to
to to an extent which will make you feel
vulnerable and unsafe because those are
pretty like existential questions to ask
yourself to look at yourself and say who
am i and what do i want and you know how
do i get it it's much easier as you say
just to be swept by the tide
and that's a form of short-term defense
it feels like a short timeist we'll just
get to tomorrow
you know yeah and some people go through
their lives doing that right oh i was
yeah i was you know i think that there's
also sort of layers of healing on issues
and so you know when i remembered the
sort of initial incident and i started
kind of string together holy cow like
all of this is connected in a really
interesting way
um compounding itself right yeah
talking about it is one layer
and it's a super important thing to do
to give yourself the gift of sitting
down with somebody who is licensed or
who has an expertise in helping you
unpack what happened
because it's only in
being able to talk through what happened
that you have the ability to start to
free yourself
from what happened like if you can't
reveal it you are definitely not going
to heal from it
and so i had done the layer of talking
about it
and then i had gone and done the layer
even underneath it of
understanding
what had happened
and understanding how it connected to
anxiety and how it connected how trauma
connected to that and understanding the
lying piece and i had even gone and done
the layer underneath that which was
starting to interrupt the old patterns
that would get triggered and put in new
patterns but it wasn't until recently
that i went to the layer that you need
to go to to truly heal
which is to repair
the nervous system
and you know
what what is uh interesting to me about
kind of even the whole journey is that
you know i've had layer after layer
after layer
for me
talking about it was very freeing
and you know people always say to me my
god you're so relatable like we open up
boom right out of the gate i tell you
something that normally somebody reveals
like an hour in
it's because i have a level of freedom
around it and i also know it's a shared
experience that so many people can
relate to on some level
um
but it wasn't until
i understood how it impacts your nervous
system and the connection between your
mind body and spirit that i began to
realize what i think it was michael
pollan or tim ferriss on one of his
podcast said which is
if you didn't talk yourself into this
[ __ ] you're not going to talk yourself
out of it like you have to have a
corresponding
physical intervention
if there was
something
physical that disrupted your body state
to begin with and that makes a lot of
sense to me it makes a lot of sense to
me that if your nervous system or your
brain recorded an experience like i can
give you a benign example
uh for people that don't that have never
really kind of thought through what
trauma actually means why it's deeply
personal how it's a physical experience
not just a mental experience so when i
was um god how old was i i guess i was i
must have been in high school we were
driving to northern michigan it was a
huge snowstorm and my mom was behind the
wheel
and my dad and my brother were in the
car in front of us
and there was a radio on and um
all of a sudden the radio announcer said
something about black ice
and this truck pulled out to try to pass
us
and
right as he tried to pass us you could
see headlights coming on
and my mom said
oh my god hold on
because the truck started to veer back
in
so i remembered the words black ice oh
my god hold on and the next thing i
remember
we were in the it was like a suv
the
car
rolled over right several times and the
experience of being in that car was like
um imagine sitting in a dryer
and you're sitting still like
but the clothes are tumbling around you
right and so like you know the
mcdonald's bag went flying past us and
the dog went flying past this and all
this stuff and we and
i remember
even though i don't remember getting
tumbled around i remember this
unbelievable sound
rolling and packing down the snow
now we ended up with the car on its side
and i was like thrown to the back seat
the dog was in the way back but my mom
was buckled in
at the top
we were fine a little shaken up i think
my mom might have had a concussion we
survived nobody died
they flipped the car back over we
climbed him with my dad off we went
now here's what's interesting about that
experience i was never scared to drive
ever i didn't ever really even think
about it
but it was a traumatic experience
because my body remembers it
and it remembers it in a certain way
i don't ever think about the experience
if i'm driving a car that's not a
trigger for my body to remember it
but if i walk to my mailbox in boston
massachusetts
after a freshly fallen snow
and i step on the snow and it goes
i feel like i'm back in that car
because that sound is a trigger for my
nervous system to remember
now that sound of me stepping on freshly
fallen snow
my mom does that all day long in
michigan and doesn't think about the
accident
but if somebody ever says the two words
black ice
around my mom
she feels like she's in that car
accident
because that's her trigger for her
nervous system to remember it so
the reason why i tell that story is
because i didn't understand trauma
i thought trauma was like for victims of
war that's what you experience if you
you know do a tour of duty somebody who
has been the victim of a super violent
crime i did not realize that trauma is a
disruption
in your nervous system
that sends your brain into a mode where
your brain like holds down the shutter
on a camera and is like snap snap snap
snap all five senses recording
everything it can possibly grab
as a way to protect you in the future
when i started to understand that oh my
god patterns of behavior get triggered
by smell they get triggered by sound
they get triggered by music they get
triggered by and the same thing with
patterns of thinking
now i had the missing piece
to be able to start to truly
reset
not only my nervous system but also the
default patterns in my mind and i
haven't looked back since
but that was step one um in terms of how
i stopped the cascade of the what if
this happens and what if that happens
and what if this happens and what and
what are they thinking and why didn't
they invite me here and when and the
universal thing that i started to
replace the what if with was what if it
all works out
what if this is the best thing that ever
happened to me
what if this is really hard and it does
suck that's not easy but it turns out to
be the best thing
that i ever did it's not easy though is
it
no it's very simple to do but it's not
easy and it's not easy
because you love
patterns like we don't it doesn't that's
not even the right way to say it it's
not easy because you're so used to
thinking a certain way and you and as
you write about you know one of the
things i scribbled down was that
you said feelings are made suggestions
ones you can ignore but we go through
life no one's ever said that to us
before we go through nice thinking that
our thoughts are ourselves and that that
is an instruction from ourselves and
that's my voice in my head telling me
what to do and i must my job is just to
obey
so if it says you know this ice means
danger then i you know
and we accept our thoughts and when i've
sat here with guests you know who have
spent a lot of time working on the brain
and understanding the difference between
thoughts and are they true and
it appears to be that you can
analyze a thought and accept or reject
which is a compelling
well
the way that i put it
or i like to think about it is this
you can be two things at once
so you can have the feeling
of being really frustrated with somebody
and that can be true
and you can also love them at the same
time
you can be jealous of somebody
and you can also allow that to inspire
you at the same time
you can be afraid which is true
and you can still
find the
willpower to push yourself or discipline
to push yourself forward you can be
deeply in a state of grief
having experienced one of the biggest
losses or betrayals of your life
and still experience a moment of joy
as you're standing on the ocean and
watching some bird dive into the sea
human beings are very complex and when
you start to understand you're not just
one thing
it gives you freedom to ride the waves
of feelings to ride the waves of
experience
and to kind of go down and go oh [ __ ]
this is a terrible thing and know
that you will
be able to come out the other side of it
and so you know i i think that
that
emotions yeah they are suggestions and
that's one way to dismantle it
another way to dismantle kind of the way
that an emotion can hook you is to keep
reminding yourself that it's temporary
this wave of pissed offness this wave of
betrayal this wave of fear this wave of
grief this wave of frustration this wave
of feeling stuck this wave of feeling
hopeless
it's temporary
it will come
and it will go
and when you realize
that emotions are temporary
it also gives you
perspective right to know that something
better is coming
and that's going to help you
be able to endure whatever it is that
you're enduring
why should you drink fuel we're going
into the fourth quarter of the year
diets are dropping off we're becoming
lazier and lazier and what tends to
happen when when our diets dip and we we
start to become less
compelled to go to the gym
is yeah we get out of shape we start to
feel low energy we start to binge eat
bad things and fuel is the antidote it's
nutritionally complete so you get
everything you need for your diet in a
drink you get your 20 grams of proteins
you're going to get your 26 vitamins and
vitamins and minerals
it's low sugar high in fiber it really
is the cure to a lot of the health
issues that we see in our personal lives
but in wider society if you've never
tried it all i'll ask you to do is give
it a try and if you like me then you
will like the world berry ready to drink
you'll like the mac and cheese which is
just selling like absolutely crazy
unsurprisingly um
you like the cinnamon
and you like the banana flavor those are
my recommendations i know a lot of
people love the chocolate flavor
let me know try it get yourself healthy
and send me a message on instagram tag
me on instagram as well on your stories
if you do try it out because i sometimes
upload those tags
and let me know which is your favorite
flavor
from you
so that was step one i dug a little
deeper on that yeah phase which was that
you know the kind of mental work what
was step two of your
level four overcoming um the the trauma
so the first step was combating the
thoughts in my head
seeing them interrupting them i'm not
thinking about that and then you know i
went a little bit further and then
started to figure out well if i think
this i'd rather be thinking this and so
then i started working on replacing the
thoughts so that the default became
different
the next step though was
a deeper understanding
of anxiety
and really studying it because i was
tired of being anxious i was tired of
taking zoloft and look zoloft saved my
life i mean i was on that drug for two
and a half decades for crying out loud
uh one of my kids takes the loft and it
helped them climb out of a hole it is i
love medication like i'm not here saying
nobody should be on medication it's the
opposite i think that you it's self-harm
not to take medication if you're in a
hole and that medication can serve as a
ladder to help you climb out of it
but i was at a point where you know i'm
45 years old i've been on this drug for
a long time i've been out teaching the
five-second rule i'm interrupting
thoughts i'm starting to feel like wow i
actually have the ability
to
not think what i have always thought i
actually have the ability to shut that
worry down and so as i started to
understand what anxiety really is
so anxiety is a really important thing
anxiety is an alarm system in your body
if you and i hop in a car and we drive
off to have dinner and a truck pulls out
right and cuts us off and you
immediately swerve what do you feel in
your body it feels like something rising
in my belly yeah making me like a little
burst of nervousness yeah yeah yeah your
heart races your armpits sweat your
hands get clammy
the alarm is sounding the alarm because
there's danger
well what happens the second the the
truck pulls away in your body well it
should go back to a calm state and i
should my
my respiratory system should start to
function as normal my dietary tract
should start to engage we should start
burning the carbs again in my belly yeah
and things should go back to normal
exactly from a biological perspective
yes exactly and the reason why that
happens is because your mind
has
the vision of the truck pulling away so
your mind tells your body threat is over
for a person that experiences anxiety
over and over and over
like at their default state what's
happened is
you're standing in your kitchen and all
of a sudden you feel that tidal wave
that you and i felt when the truck
pulled into our lane
but there's no threat
and so as the rush hits your body your
mind starts scrambling looking for what
in the kitchen is threatening me and
there's nothing there
and since you know the science of the
body all the blood when you go into
fight or flight goes to your major
organs it leaves your digestive tract
your stomach starts to gurgle most
people think butterflies means they're
[ __ ] no butterflies just means the
blood left your stomach to go to your
heart and now your digestive chemistry
has changed that's all that's happening
it doesn't mean you're about to die
but we misread it because we don't
understand it and so then once you go oh
i'm [ __ ] my stomach hurts and now i'm
feeling now your mind escalates it and
your mind starts freaking out and when
your mind starts freaking out then your
body freaks out more and that's when the
grand panic attack happens which is an
emergency break it's it's designed to
get you to stop thinking and to just
remove yourself and if you've ever seen
somebody have a panic attack they dart
around a room
they can't breathe and they feel like
they've got to leave whatever situation
they're in
this is how your body's designed
to get you out of emergencies
the problem with somebody who gets a
dysregulated nervous system
is you feel like a truck's about to pull
in your lane all the time but your brain
can't understand why you feel that way
because there is no truck
your body just got stuck there
and so when i started to understand that
i found this really interesting piece of
research um from harvard medical school
called reframing performance anxiety
where researchers wanted to know
since you know people really screw up
tests when they get nervous
right you know you get nervous about a
test and then you can't focus and so you
blow it because you've got performance
anxiety or athletes that really blow it
when they get nervous before a game
well medically speaking
there is no physiological difference
in your body state physiologically
speaking
between being nervous and being excited
zero difference so exactly what you
talked about when the truck pulled into
the lane in the example that i gave that
experience that made you feel nervous
when you feel excited
the same thing happens your heart races
the blood leaves your digestive tract
and goes up to your major organs your
armpits start to sweat your throat feels
tight your hands get clammy exact same
physiological experience
excitement and nervous the only
difference between a situation that
makes you excited in a situation that
makes you nervous is what your brain is
saying about what's happening
so if you're in a situation where you're
like oh my god i'm going to screw up
this test you know it's gonna be
terrible and you start working yourself
up and i'm so nervous i'm so nervous i'm
gonna blow this interview i'm so nervous
of course you're gonna start sweating of
course your heart's gonna race
if you and i are about to go see
our favorite musician let's say we have
front row tickets adele is going to play
right here in london we are right there
oh my god she's about to come on stage
my heart's racing my armpits are
sweating
i'm excited because my brain's going
adele's about to be there
so the body
makes sense in the excitement situation
so the researchers at harvard wanted to
know well
given that physiologically it's the
exact same experience
is it possible to trick the drain brain
in a moment when you're nervous and make
your brain think you're excited and if
you did trick your brain in a moment
when you were nervous to believe that
you were actually excited would it
impact your ability to perform and the
answer is yes you can trick your brain
in a situation where you're nervous to
believe that you're actually excited
and yes
it profoundly impacts your ability to
perform
and so they put people in control groups
in um like a karaoke competition a
negotiation competition a standardized
test and a track meet
and there were only uh the only
difference between the groups is one
group was taught in a situation that
made them nervous to simply say as dumb
as this sounds
i'm so excited
i'm so excited to run this race i'm so
excited to take this test i'm so excited
to get out there and sing even though
they felt nervous i'm so excited
and the people that were taught to say
i'm so excited
outperformed the people
who had no tools
and the reason can be explained by
chemistry and physiology and neurology
if you get too nervous
and you start to get too worked up and
your thoughts start to spin
and your body stays in a fight or flight
state
your brain releases cortisol and
cortisol impacts your brain's ability to
focus
so all your preparation
goes out the window because you just
blew it with the cortisol in your brain
when you say i'm excited even if you
feel
nervous
your brain buys it and doesn't release
cortisol
which allows you to focus on what you
need to do
and so i started experimenting with this
because i was deathly afraid of flying
and at the age of 45 i'm now all of a
sudden because of that tedx talk
starting to take off on the speaking
circuit and i'm having to board planes
and i'm being bombarded with these
thoughts of i'm going to die i'm never
going to see my kids get married i is my
husband going to remarry you know will i
make it and so i said i got to figure
out a better way and so i stumbled into
this project and i came up with this
strategy and this is freaking genius
i've taught it to millions of people
it's curing people's anxiety
i kid you not therapists are using this
around the world it is extraordinary
so before you have to do something that
makes you nervous
come up with
uh
anything that you can grab onto
that makes you
excited about what you're doing so for
example with the example of flying
before i get on an airplane i mean i'm
not afraid to fly at all anymore but
back in the day back when i eight years
ago before i would get on a plane so i'm
flying to london
i would think of something i'm excited
to do
when i get to london
and so before i board that plane in
boston i would think about
coming here and meeting stephen and
getting to hang out with them
when i get on that plane
and we're up in the air and all of a
sudden we start bouncing around like you
know something yeah like turbulence in
the air and my body goes oh my god
i close my eyes and go i am so excited
to see stephen this is going to be
amazing and what happens
is that my mind goes
hold on hold on she's not nervous
she's excited to see steven
and your body literally settles
and your mind locks on to this thing
that makes sense because i'm going to
london i'm going to see you and if i'm
going to see you the plane obviously
makes it so there's nothing to worry
about and it took me about five or six
times of doing it
and i stopped having any kind of anxiety
whatsoever about flying it's really
interesting so many different my brain
fizzled off into so many different like
flowcharts
but um you know a lot of people talk
about anxiety being this like concern
about the future right
and
from one perspective i was thinking then
as you're saying that what you're
actually doing is making the future uh
a really nice place so your brain is
saying this plane is going to crash the
future is death yeah and you're it
sounded like you're hijacking it in fact
in fact brain the future is really
really pleasant i get to go and see
stephen yeah which and it's like that's
what it sounded like but but i have to i
just completely resonate and then anyone
that's really listened to to me even in
two episodes ago one of the questions i
was asked was about imposter syndrome
and my response to that was i don't
necessarily feel like i've experienced
imposter syndrome and the example i give
is when i'm in brazil and i know i'm
going up on stage and obama's there
for me
i i always say this on the podcast i
have the same butterflies everyone
else's house but my brain is telling me
that i'm excited right and it's done
that so many times and because i think
because it does that and then it goes
well
it's reinforcing that that is in fact
excitement and next time you're you know
and it's and it's kept that fear at bay
can i unpack what just happened
so for most people
butterflies in your stomach
is a trigger
that makes you believe something bad's
about to happen
and i have a theory about it
the number one fear
in kids is throwing up
number two is their parents dying
but number one according to
pediatricians
is the fear of throwing up because this
is this intense moment of losing control
and so
tons of little kids
have an enormous fear of throwing up
and the trigger of your stomach rumbling
or butterflies
triggers that fear and so i think
there's been a lifetime negative
association with having butterflies
what you did is you took a very common
experience that's a negative trigger for
people
so the physical sensation of your
stomach being upset triggers negative
thought patterns uh oh uh oh uh oh i'm
in trouble i'm trouble i'm in trouble
yeah and then that sticks
what you've done is you've hijacked it
and you've labeled that feeling in your
stomach as something positive i'm really
excited 100 but i don't deserve credit
for that because it was never it was
i've i figured that out in hindsight
only from
hearing someone that suffers with nerves
and then seeing the consequence of the
the impact that nerves have when they go
up on stage and me being like okay i
have that bit
i have the feeling but my brain isn't
fearful and then it goes well for me and
that reinforces me and creates this
compounding positive cycle in my life
now where i can walk up on stage with
obama and yeah i'm feeling it backstage
but i'm like i can't wait to get off on
stage right and this kind of speaks to a
confidence all of these things because
once you get stuck in that negative
reinforcing downward cycle and i'd say
it the downward cycle goes much faster
than the upward cycle like one incident
can make that confidence drop and then
um it's hard to get out of it's hard to
get other you know
i guess hijacking it in the way you've
described is
is a definite solution
well you know what
i just got really excited about
is that
let's go back to the fact that your
brain learns
patterns and
even though you may feel stuck
even though you may feel hopeless
you're not broken
you have patterns of thinking and
patterns of behavior that are broken
for where you are and where you want to
go in life
and what's super exciting
is that when you start to think about
changing your life
through the lens of just looking for
patterns breaking them and replacing
them it becomes less personal
and i believe especially after what i've
experienced with the high five habit
that
you know there's a lot of research in in
habits obviously about how long it takes
a new habit to stick
and
it's anywhere from according to a lot of
people 21 days to 63 days depending upon
what you're looking at in terms of the
mind body spirit i personally have a
theory that if you don't like the new
habit you're never gonna make it stick
like i don't like getting out of bed in
the morning i've been using the five
second rule five four three two one for
13 years can we talk about that i feel
like we haven't brushed over that little
bit so this five-second rule uh-huh um
you released the book i think 2017
called the five-second rule and it's all
about you know well you tell me what
it's about where it came from i know
there was a rocket you're watching a
rocket on tv
um and that was a little bit of the
initial inspiration but where did this
come from and what is it well so you
know i think i alluded to earlier that
um
it seems like
my version of personal development
requires me to fall into a hole or dig
one and then i realize nobody's coming
to rescue me and i'm if i want to get
out of the hole i'm going to need to
build a freaking ladder
and so at the age of 40
i found myself in a
place that i just never envisioned i
would be
and that is uh i had my husband and i
had three kids under the age of 10
and i was unemployed
and my husband had been in the
restaurant business with his best friend
and the housing crisis
hit especially hit in the united states
and we found ourselves 800 grand in debt
because we had secured the restaurant
business like complete morons with our
kids college fund and our house and
every credit card and the home equity
line and the cars and everything
and that's great when your business is
working it's absolutely terrifying when
it's not and so i would wake up every
morning
just pinned to the bed with anxiety
and i
became somebody that i barely recognized
i was screaming at crisps i was drinking
myself into the ground i
the kids were missing the bus every day
i didn't have a job i was hiding from my
friends i hadn't told my family what was
going on
and you know
the thing that's that's that's
interesting about
being
stuck in life is that
the fact is you know what you need to do
that's the easy part and if you don't
know what you need to do to improve the
situation and
google it
there's approximately a bazillion videos
out there of people
like you that have been in the exact
same situation they will walk you
through how to there are books you can
buy their courses the the what you need
to do is out there
it's the how
how the [ __ ] do you make yourself do
what you need to do
when you are scared or overwhelmed or
anxious or hopeless or depressed or any
of the stuff that happens to you as a
human
that's the 100 million dollar question
and at the time i didn't have the answer
i knew i needed to look for a job i knew
i needed to stop streaming at chris i
knew i needed to get the kids on the bus
i knew i needed to ask for help i wasn't
doing any of those things
i was stuck in broken patterns and i
didn't know any of the things that we're
talking about right now
but one night you know i was sitting
there and i was watching tv and i was
telling myself tomorrow morning it's got
to be the new you i've given myself that
lame pep talk like mel you've got to
stop drinking you have got to be nice to
chris you've got to pull your [ __ ]
together you got to look for a job and
by god woman when that alarm rings you
cannot lay there like a human pot roast
marinating in fear and staring at the
ceiling you have got to get out of bed
woman and then all of a sudden this is
divine intervention
the rocket ship launches across a
television screen stephen and i say
that's it
that's it tomorrow morning when the
alarm goes off mel robbins you're going
to launch yourself out of bed like a
rocket ship you're going to move so fast
you're not going to be in that bed when
that anxiety hits
now it was either god or bourbon one of
those two things gave me the idea
because it sounds dumb okay mal you're
going to beat anxiety by moving fast
that sounds great
well the very next morning
it was a tuesday in february outside of
boston massachusetts in 2008.
the alarm went off
and i think a lot about this moment
because if i
hadn't
done what i did that morning
my life would have gone in a totally
different direction
i'd probably be divorced i'd probably be
an alcoholic my family would be torn
apart
no idea what i'd be doing for a living
or where i would be
and i
profoundly believe
that you are one decision away
from a different life
and that happened to me on a february
morning in 2008.
the alarm rang
and
as soon as the alarm rang i remembered
the idea of launching myself out of bed
and then i did
what psychologists call
a bias toward thinking and this window
opens up when you start to think about
what you need to do instead of doing
what you need to do
it's this window of hesitation that's
about five seconds long
a window of hesitation that defines your
whole life
inside this window of hesitation
lives anxiety and procrastination and
fear and impostor syndrome and overwhelm
all patterns of thinking all patterns of
feeling all patterns of behavior
that get triggered
in this five second window of thinking
about what you need to do
because it's in the thinking that you go
from being present to all the patterns
kicking in and the coping mechanisms
that you have
and so for whatever reason i started to
think about getting up and all the [ __ ]
started to come in i don't feel like it
how's it going to help i don't want to
for whatever reason
i just started counting backwards
five four three two one
and i stood up
and
i used it the next morning and the next
morning and by the third morning
i was kind of freaked out because i'm
like okay
this is working
this is weird
and i said
mel i made myself a promise
if at any moment
you know what you need to do but you
don't feel like it
just count backwards and let's just see
what happens
and so i started using it steve in this
little count backwards technique 54321
no idea why it's working by the way
um in any moment i'd see chris i'd want
to kill him five four three two one all
of a sudden i'm calm i can speak to him
from a more supportive place kids are
irritating five for three two one take a
breath and now i can be the mom that i
know i want to be 54321 i'm going out
the door to exercise 54321 i'm picking
up the phone and i'm networking 5 or 321
i'm picking up the phone and calling my
parents and asking for help
and slowly but surely one decision at a
time using the five second rule and the
five second rule is very simple the
moment you have an instinct to move you
gotta do it within five seconds or your
brain will kill it
and counting backwards is critical
i now know why it works when you count
backwards five four three two one you
interrupt habit loops stored in your
basal ganglia
and the counting backwards requires
focus so it awakens this sucker right
here your prefrontal cortex
it's referred to as a starting ritual in
habit research
a cheat code for your brain
and um
basically i used it in secret for three
years because i mean what am i going to
do tell people you can count to five and
you change your life i mean it sounds
ridiculous
plus i was just trying to survive
i'm trying to like find a job and
save my marriage and help my husband and
make sure my kids are okay and start to
pay our bills make the ends meet and
that's what i was doing and
one thing led to another and
word got out about it and people started
to write to me about it and um it has
now gone on to change the lives of
millions of people we know of 111 people
who have stopped themselves from
attempting suicide by counting backwards
54321
when i had a daytime talk show an entire
wing of
nurses from an inpatient unit at a
psychiatric hospital in philadelphia
came to my talk show and explained to me
after the show that of all the tools
that they have
when they discharge somebody from an
inpatient commitment that the five
second rule is the most effective thing
that they have
except for medication obviously but it's
the most effective thing that they have
because it's simple
and you can remember it
and anybody can use it
and it works
and
i think we make a huge mistake in life
we make the mistake of believing
that because our problems are big or
because our dreams are so big
that somehow the solution
to achieving
those dreams or to solving those
problems must be enormous too
when in truth it's the opposite
the larger the problem the smaller the
solution
the bigger the dream the smaller the
actions are that you need to start
taking
super compelling because that also
has a lot of similarities with your with
your new book
the high five habit it does yeah so i'd
love to hear the story of um
of how this was born and i imagine
you know that that came out of as you
said a low point in your life where you
were you were looking for
what you thought would probably be a
complex solution to a set of complex
sort of problems and dynamics in your
life but
um the high five habit is more centered
around gratitude and
um
i guess like self-appreciation is that
an accurate description of that yeah
yeah like it's um
you know even knowing what i know about
the five-second rule
i believe the five habit is
a thousand times more powerful
and the reason why i say that is because
the five-second rule will help you break
patterns of behavior it'll help you push
through fear it'll help you take action
it'll help you interrupt thoughts
it will help you walk away from things
define boundaries um it's very action
oriented overcome procrastination yeah
overcome procrastination
the high five habit works at a much
deeper level
it
solves
what i believe is everybody's core
issue and problem
and that is
the issue and the habit of hating
yourself
of criticizing yourself of not liking
yourself
of beating yourself up
and
as successful as i've become and as much
as i've accomplished
it wasn't until i stumbled into the high
five habit that i truly confronted the
fact that
in spite of all that success i still
didn't like myself
i still judge the woman in the mirror i
was still in many ways betting against
myself by constantly beating the hell
out of myself and it was a habit
and you know we talked in the very
beginning about how
we go from being children that are wired
to love ourselves to
the ways in which life can make you
start to feel what's wrong with me and
the ways in which your brain starts to
turn and filter the world in a way where
you see everything that you're not and
all the ways that you don't fit in and
all the things that aren't working out
and that was exactly my experience and i
think it's every single human being's
experience i don't care how successful
you are
and so the high five habit is very very
simple and first i'll tell you what it
is and then i'll explain the story
so i'm on a mission
to get every single human being on the
planet
to add
high fiving themselves in the mirror to
their morning routine
that right after you brush your teeth as
ubiquitous as it is for people to brush
their teeth in the morning let's get rid
of the skanky breath so you don't drag
it through your day
i want you to literally wipe clean your
mind body and spirit
so you don't drag generational gunk and
patterns into your day
and it's that simple put down the
toothbrush look at yourself in the
mirror raise your hand and send yourself
into your day
knowing that you
have your own back knowing that no
matter what happens today
you will be here
there to support you and encourage you
no matter what
because you haven't been
and um the way i discovered it was um in
april of 2020 and you know the backdrop
doesn't even matter i mean what was
happening is a universal experience i
was just at a moment
where
i was overwhelmed by my life
there was a lot of [ __ ] going on in my
business there was a lot of stuff going
on in the world
a couple of my kids were really in a
state of being anxious and upset about
things and
i just woke up morning after morning
feeling the weight of the world on my
shoulders
feeling like if one more thing happened
i just can't cope
and
i think that that's something that we
all feel at times in our life whether
somebody just breaks up with you or you
lose a job or you don't get the funding
you wanted or you lose an election you
went for or you just
feel
lost in your life or maybe your parents
are sick just this feeling of i just
can't take it i just don't know how i'm
going to deal with the demands of my
life and that was me
and so one morning i'm standing in my
bathroom
and i'm brushing my teeth and i'm there
in my underwear and i look at myself in
the mirror and my first thought is
oh my god
you look like
hell
and then
i immediately
out of habit
start picking my appearance apart
i mean look at the dark circles in your
gray hair and your saggy neck and god
one boob is lower than the other you
look like [ __ ] mel
and the second your mind goes negative
you already alluded to this it's like
you know more negative thoughts climb on
and so then i drift into my day and it's
not like yes it's like why did i get up
so late you got a zoom call in eight
minutes oh my god i haven't even walked
the dog yet and oh i forgot to text
steven back and just the beat down
begins
and i believe
that my experience that morning is
everybody's experience and i know based
on research that it is
that we talk a big game about gratitude
and and meditation and morning routines
but we've skipped this one thing that's
happening in everybody's morning routine
and it's a habit of self-rejection
of self-criticism
and every human being has it i kid you
not
and
standing there that morning overwhelmed
by life giving myself the morning just
kind of beat down and you know
negativity
i couldn't think of anything to say to
myself and i wouldn't have believed it
anyway because i felt overwhelmed
and as pathetic as it sounds
i don't know what came over me
but for whatever reason again i think it
was probably divine intervention
i just
dog at my feet
underwear on no bra i just raised my
hand
and i gave the woman in the mirror a
high five
because she looked like she needed one
that very first one a couple things
happened i actually laughed because it
was so cheesy i now know that the reason
why i laughed is because your brain
drips dopamine
when you give somebody a high five
and then i felt like a
switch flip
and it wasn't like i was like yes
but i just felt
myself go from this very low state
i didn't even think any words but
energetically i felt myself go from
feeling defeated
to sort of a like come on now
you got a roof over your head it's not
that bad get your ass out like it was
kind of like that kind of tough coach
kind of
mustering of an energy
but stephen it was the second morning
when everything broke wide open
so i wake up same problem same kind of
energetic depleted overwhelm
54321 i get out of bed
i make my bed
and as i'm walking to the bathroom i'm
not even to the bathroom yet and then it
fricking hits me
i realize i'm experiencing something
i've never felt in my entire adult life
and what i'm experiencing is this
when you go and you're about to meet
somebody at a cafe that you really love
and you're about to walk in the door
what are you feeling
excitement positive
anticipation um yeah yeah
i felt that
about seeing myself
now i felt excited
to see an outfit
or haircut
i don't ever recall as an adult
feeling
excited
to see the human being mel robbins
why were you excited
i was excited because
the experience of high-fiving yourself
is more than a gesture
it creates partnership
and there's a sense that you're
returning home
the same way that a neighbor waves to
you
and sees you
i knew that i would have that experience
with myself as soon as i rounded the
corner
and walked into that bathroom
because what i realized that second
morning as i ran at the corner and
walked into the bathroom
is that there's actually two human
beings in the bathroom every morning
there's you
and there's a human being in the mirror
and that human being is trying
and they've been there a long time
and they've been waiting for you to wake
up
and to see them
they're tired of your constant
negativity they're tired of you beating
them down
they need you to be more encouraging
they need you
to be
more celebratory
they need your support
and when you
finally wake up
and create a moment with yourself
every single morning
where you look yourself in the eye
and you see yourself
and you forgive yourself and you honor
yourself
and you
say i believe
with this gesture in you
it is this remarkably deep and spiritual
feeling
of connection that you've been longing
for for a very long time
and so that second morning you know i'm
realizing holy cow it's like this sort
of it's sort of like when you first
realize that the voice in your head
isn't you
and you have this whole paradigm shift
when you allow yourself
to understand the depth of what i'm
trying to teach you
there will be a paradigm shift
that will
fundamentally change how you live your
life
the hardest part is looking at yourself
50 of men and women
cannot or will not
look at themselves in the mirror because
they are either disgusted or
disappointed
with where they are in life
and if you cannot look at yourself in
the mirror
that is an act of self-rejection
that is an act of self-criticism that is
an act of self-hatred
that's not just a casual thing you're
doing
the rest of us that can look at
ourselves
what we do when we look at ourselves as
we focus on the things we need to fix
for most women putting on makeup is not
additive it's not a creative expression
it's covering something up that you
don't like
it's changing something that you think
is wrong
that action that intention behind it is
self-rejection
it is self-criticism it is self-hatred
and for so many men if it's not about
your appearance it's about where you are
in life what you've provided how much
you've made what car you drive where you
stand in your career what you've built
what you haven't the mistakes that
you've made
so you stand in judgment
and
what is so
groundbreaking
about the act of
being where you are in life
even with all that judgment or that
weight or that shame or that regret or
whatever it may be that you carry into
the bathroom with you based on your life
when you raise your hand to high five
the human being you see in the mirror
your brain has neural association with
that physical action the physical action
in and of itself is a positive trigger
for every human being on the planet even
if you are in a culture
where people do not high five each other
you have seen sports teams do it you
have seen viral videos with it your
brain knows exactly what a high five is
just like everybody's brain knows
exactly what this is
you don't even have to say a word
because all of the positive programming
is already hardwired into your basal
ganglia and the physical action alone
triggers it
you know you've never high-fived
somebody and thought i hate you you suck
you've blown your life i hope you lose
the game [ __ ] off you've never ever done
it
it is neurologically impossible
to stand in front of the mirror and
actually think something negative as
your hand is reaching the mirror because
your brain's not programmed to do that
so when you high-five somebody what are
what does the high five communicate
well done
acceptance congratulations
you did it you can do it let's do it um
yeah well done it's collaboration it's
partnership it's union mm-hmm yeah
if somebody's going through a challenge
let's shake it off you got this keep
going
it is so many things but it's all in
belief and celebration and being seen
all of which are your fundamental
emotional needs
and so the thing that's super exciting
about this is that we're taking
programming
that is already stored in your mind body
and spirit and we're just going to aim
it right back at you
and the layers upon layers upon layers
of
psychological proof of research of all
kinds of evidence for why this works
goes so deep it's extraordinary
so
for example the physical action of
high-fiving your brain has already
always given you a drip of dopamine
that's why you will immediately feel a
boost in your mood it's why a lot of
people laugh
the other thing that happens is
you are also tapping into wiring in your
nervous system that's celebratory so
when you cross a finish line for example
or when your favorite team scores what
do you instinctively do celebrate yeah
you raise your arms shout surprise you
raise your arms when you say hello you
raise your arms when you go to high-five
somebody you raise your arms so even on
your lowest morning when you go to raise
your arm to high-five yourself
your nervous system taps into that
celebratory energy that we all so
desperately need in life
the other thing that happens that i love
about this is you don't need to say a
word
because for many people who feel
extraordinarily stuck
and beaten down and full of shame or
regret you wouldn't believe any positive
mantras anyway because you've got so
much evidence for
why you're a screw-up why things aren't
working but when you go to raise your
hand
the gesture does all the communicating
and it also taps into behavioral
activation therapy
which says at its most simple form act
like the person you want to become
that's not fake it till you make it by
the way
this is intentional
intentionally act like the person you
want to become
because when you intentionally act like
the person you want to become your brain
sees you taking those actions so your
brain starts to change the way it
relates to you
when your brain sees you high-fiving
yourself in the mirror it starts to go
oh
wait a minute
stephen loves himself
steven's cheering for himself we don't
beat steven up
do you see a difference when you between
doing it with yourself and doing it with
someone else oh it's not well
it's night and day in that you've been
cheering for everybody else your whole
life
and when somebody else high-fives you it
feels amazing because you're getting
affirmed as a human being it's
connection as well it's connection
but i believe you can create that same
connection with yourself
and what's happened for me is profound i
mean i you know used to look in the
mirror and on default pick myself apart
it was never enough didn't matter how
many millions of dollars i made it was
never enough i was no no no and i
realize now like so many entrepreneurs i
had married achievement with being
worthy of love
that as long as i was achieving
something then i was worthy of love and
that's also why we all tend to chase
achievement because the second that you
get the first million in the bank okay
now i gotta do more
because if you're not doing something
then who are you
and
in practicing the high five habit for
now more than a year and researching it
for more than a year
in having hundreds of thousands of
people go through this thing that we
call the high five challenge we've
released it to the public now for 34
days we've had 136 000 people complete
it from 91 countries
not a single person because we're
tracking all the data on it has said it
didn't work
not a single person
we have people writing to us about the
breakthroughs they're having with
depression with anxiety with suicidal
ideation with self-worth with senses of
failure because it's the physical action
and the programming that exists within
you that go to work against the patterns
that are making you feel so dark and
stuck and that's why this is powerful
and so after a year of doing this
what's amazing is i don't even see my
face anymore
i just see a person that i love
you know being a parent it's pretty
extraordinary
um you have this experience when when
you become a parent or even a pet owner
right
where you love this thing so much
even when the dog poops on the ground
you're angry but you don't stop loving
the dog
when your kids screw up you might be
annoyed or regret what they did but you
don't stop loving them
but somehow we never figured out how to
do that for ourselves
that when we screw up we stop loving
ourselves
and we stand in judgment instead
and i think that's why life is hard
i think that's why people don't feel
inspired and motivated
you want to
fix impostor syndrome and
people-pleasing
learn how to stand in front of the
mirror
give yourself a high five demonstrate
that you like yourself demonstrate that
you accept yourself because if you like
yourself
you don't go out in the world and look
for other people to like you because you
don't need it
it's wonderful if they do but the
fantastic thing is if you actually like
yourself
if you just accept where you are you
stop judging yourself you accept
yourself with some compassion
what's extraordinarily powerful about it
stephen is that
when you go out in the world if somebody
else disrespects you it doesn't change
the fact that you respect yourself
if somebody else doesn't like you or
love you yeah it stings it sucks but it
doesn't change the fact that you like or
love yourself that's your first
foundation that's your first foundation
and this
high-five habit
of standing in partnership with yourself
demonstrating through a physical action
that you see yourself you support
yourself you got you you got your own
back you like yourself you know you
deserve to be treated this way it
changes how you show up in life
quick one as you probably know by now
i'm trying to make my life a little bit
more sustainable and i consider myself
to be on a bit of a sustainability
journey in the same way that i'm on a
health journey and it's a privilege to
be able to share that with all of you
and you you'll know if you've listened
to the last podcast that i traded in my
range rover sport in for an electric
bicycle which is now my only vehicle and
next year hopefully i'll have my
electric car too if tesla hurry up with
a cybertrack and that's where my energy
comes into my life and my sort of
sustainability journey it makes your
life if you are on that sustainability
journey ten times easier this is one of
the if you can't see this i'm holding up
my hand if you're listening on spotify
apple this is one of their renewable
energy products if you're watching on
youtube you'll you'll see this this is
called the harvey it's this very clever
little device that allows the zappy and
the eddie which i've talked about before
on this podcast to be installed into
your home without hard wiring or without
batteries or without those um god-awful
transformers that a lot of people have
in their house it's basically a tiny
device that's going to save you both
time and money and for someone like me
who doesn't have loads of time on our
hands it's a real life saver if you're
looking to make a conscious switch and
you need a quick fix that's going to
save you a load of time then head over
to myenergy.com to see this product and
many many more
a lot of self-help advice tends to
advise like looking in the mirror
and just like saying nice [ __ ] to
yourself like i am
strong and capable and i will be a
millionaire and then like crack on with
you if that worked we'd all be
millionaires yeah
but so that doesn't work because there's
a lot of people wait isn't that how you
made your millions
didn't you just stand in front of a
mirror and say i'm a billionaire i'm
going to be a millionaire i would have
been like then i went back to bed
there's a lot of like that narrative in
society and this is like it's [ __ ]
it's interlinked with the manifestation
piece which is from what i've a lot of
the fluffy stuff that i read is like you
just got to think about it in fact i had
this argument with this girl one day in
new york
where she was like steve all you got to
do is think about it and it will happen
so you don't believe there's any work
involved nope just think about it and i
was like i don't
that sounds like somebody with a trust
fund
and the the analogy i often give is like
if i just did the sat nav in my car and
didn't put the key in and press the
accelerator i would just be in my garage
all day like i understand the importance
of knowing where you're going which is
the sat nav but i also have to drive
or else we're not going to move yeah so
um couple things
positive mantras don't work
and they don't work because people pick
positive mantras that they don't believe
so if you are
in a studio apartment eating rice and
beans barely able to pay your bills
standing in front of a mirror and saying
i'm a millionaire i'm going to be a
millionaire someday
what happens based on research is your
brain's like uh actually
have you seen where you live
like have you seen that you've quit
every job that you've had have you seen
and heard your negative self-talk i
don't i don't think that's gonna like
your brain's like uh-uh
your brain has a great [ __ ] detector
and so
the mistake people make is they pick a
mantra
that is the exact opposite of the way
they treat themselves is it like
so the way that i've come to maybe even
in the last two months is my brain
actually needs evidence yes right yes
like so and you know what evidence at
once
it wants [ __ ] action right
oh yeah prove it to me behavioral
activation therapy act like the person
you say you want to be and then maybe
i'll believe you yeah now should you
still interrupt the beat down
absolutely
absolutely you should
what i'm saying is you got to stop
beating the hell out of yourself
but you can't jump immediately to and
it's going to all magically disappear
and i'm going to love my body after
beating myself up and hating myself for
20 years it's not going to happen that
fast so you know if you want to do
mantras do a more pathetic mantra you
know do something that's like a little
bit like more achievable like you know
instead of uh you know i love my body
after trashing your body for 20 years
say i deserve to be healthy
even if
you hate your body anybody and any brain
can get behind yeah you do that's right
i'm glad you're waking up you do deserve
to be healthy
now now prove it let's take some actions
that show you that so no monitors don't
work if you're picking a mantra you
don't believe and if you're picking a
mantra that is the opposite of the way
you treat yourself and the actions you
take so that's number one number two
manifesting everybody has been sold a
bill of goods about manifesting
if you make a vision board with your
house on the ocean or you at the stock
exchange ringing the bell and that's all
that you have on it
science says
that that vision board will become a
source of
profound discouragement
because over time as you sit there and
stare at your dream house or you ring
the bell at nasdaq and
nothing in your life changes
you start to feel further and further
and further away from what you want
which makes you feel further and further
discouraged which means you're less and
less motivated to even begin working on
it like the hardest part for everybody
is to start and the reason why is not
only the patterns of procrastination and
anxiety and stuff that you get trapped
in but it's also because your goals feel
so far away
that you don't
believe that just starting is gonna even
chip away at it and so number one
because it sounds like i just
contradicted myself
yes
you need to have something like a beach
house or the nasdaq bell or the business
you're starting or the love affair of
your life or the family you've always
envisioned or the
health that you've always dreamt about
absolutely swing for the fences what do
you want it to look like 10 years from
now
but when it comes to manifesting based
on science i want you to think as
manifesting as a bridge
manifesting is a bridge
that's made of bricks
between you
and the thing that you dream about
and what you do when you manifest is you
don't manifest where the bridge is going
you manifest the bricks
so a great example is a marathon so
let's say that you've never run a day in
your life but your bucket list is to
complete the london marathon
yes you can put on your vision board
a photograph of a runner crossing the
london marathon you can even put the
dream that you have in terms of the the
number that you want the time to be okay
but you better put a runner in the rain
up there
you better put an alarm clock that says
4 30 in the morning because that's what
time you're gonna have to get up in
order to get your training runs in
you better put a runner that's gripping
their leg like this when they get a
muscle cramp you better put up uh you
know a vision of you
at mile 13 and your earbuds run out
and you still got two more miles to go
visualization
is the bricks and so what i want you to
do when you visualize is instead of
visualizing ah
the marathon i did it i was amazing and
then you open up you're like okay and i
still have not even bought a pair of
sneakers
that's not happening but that was a fun
little exercise no what you do is you
literally visualize walk into the store
and get sneakers
call your friend who runs and ask for
advice
oh my god that's me and my first
training run i've only gone 30 seconds
and i'm out of breath
oh there i am running three miles in the
rain and i feel proud of myself because
i've actually gone out in the rain oh
there i am saying uh no to my friends i
can't go out tonight because i didn't
get my run in but i'm gonna go on my big
run alone that like you visualize the
annoying irritating amazing things i'm
sure people look at you all the time
with your extraordinary success stephen
and are like how'd you do it how'd you
do it and
like do you know how many things i
missed that on do you know how many
like how like the amount of work that
nobody wants to do because they're not
thinking about it
is extraordinary that's the bridge
anybody is capable of achieving anything
i actually believe that because i think
human beings are designed to change
you're capable of breaking any pattern
you're capable of getting control of
your health you're capable of launching
a business you're capable of making
millions of dollars you're capable of
healing your trauma of finding love of
doing absolutely anything
that you put your mind to
as long as you are willing to do the
work for it and as long as you give up
your timeline
because i do believe
that
people who put in the work
get rewarded
but you just
might not get rewarded
when you think you're going to be
and it might not be the reward
that you thought you were going to get
is that the case in your life
it's always the case
and that's why i always have big dreams
because i have learned time and time and
time and time again especially in
entrepreneurial ventures
that you put this huge flag out there
you write the business plan you set the
goals and then you put your [ __ ] head
down and you put in the work
and you
ride the wave and you have the
disappointments and you spend the late
nights and you have the heartbreak and
the heartache and then things change and
then you think [ __ ] this didn't work out
and i got betrayed and why didn't they
recognize me and damn it i've worked
hard and now i got to start all over and
you have all of that but if you keep
going
and you keep going
eventually you will look up one day and
be like holy [ __ ]
this
is exactly
what i was meant to do and what i was
meant to discover
yeah my business plan said i was
supposed to go over here
and i ended up over here because this is
what i was supposed to do
but without this business plan
i never would have gotten started
the business plan was but a dot on the
map of my life
connecting me to where i meant to go
you know i think one of the most
extraordinary things that has happened
to me in this past year especially
now that i have this real partnership
with myself
where i have a
level of trust
that through my attitude through my
actions through a sense of faith
that
it's going to turn out
that even when things are really hard i
still believe deep in my core
that through my attitude and my actions
it's gonna be okay
that i have within me the power to ride
the ups and downs and to come out on the
other side of it
and
you know i think that we've all had the
experience stephen of being able to look
backwards and say
whoa you know i wouldn't ever wish
the experience that i had
back in fourth grade on anybody
but without that experience
i would not be able to help the amount
of people that i help
i would not be able to understand trauma
as a lived experience
and inside and out and at a layer that's
so deep because it is an experience that
i
had in my life without 25 years of
struggling with anxiety without having
two kids that have struggled with
anxiety i would not know what i know
about anxiety and be able to help people
including my own children
i would not without having made mistakes
with my kids and their anxiety be able
to tell parents do not do this because i
did this and it made my kids anxiety
worse and i didn't even know
and so i can see you know i can see how
everything from you know working as a
public defender to being a legal
commentator from cnn to the number of
stages that i've been on to the number
of people that i've helped i can see how
all of that comes together
to help me do what i need to do in this
moment
and i think one of the most powerful
things that you can cultivate
when you cultivate partnership with
yourself
is being able every single day to have a
level of trust
in your life
in the magic of things in yourself to
know that this moment right now
is also a dot on the map of your life
and 5 10 20 years from now you will look
back on this moment
and you will know exactly why this
happened
and why it happened is it was preparing
you for something
it was giving you a skill or an
experience or some wisdom or a
relationship that you're going to need
for something extraordinary that's
coming
and when you believe that
it gives you the strength to face
absolutely anything
when you look back on
the person you are now mm-hmm and the
tremendous wisdom that you've just
demonstrated just speaking to me just
then
do you recognize
the male that was
couldn't get out of bed was feeling
depressed
couldn't find you know described herself
as you as you did as being lazy do you
recognize that person and what's at the
very essence in the engine room that
drove that change was it
passion
was it finding your calling
um because i know you weren't this per
and you couldn't have been this person
dude it's also been 31 years i mean come
on i've had i've like basically been
changing for as long as you've been
alive for crying out loud
and also human beings are designed to
grow
but not everybody seems to because you
have because they don't understand being
stuck
yeah interesting
see
being stuck is one of the most universal
feelings of the human experience and
nobody understands what it is
what is it oh it's amazing when you hear
this it's like
so remember how we've talked about how
uh the
human beings have this crazy amount of
natural intelligence wired into us and
inside your body we've talked about one
of the signals anxiety anxiety is a
signal that means pay attention
that's why you go into fight or flight
you're in an alert mode okay
that's all it is it's a signal an alarm
system and your body has a sophisticated
system of signals and alarms
and they're all tied to fundamental
needs
anxiety is tied to your fundamental need
for safety that's why it's a signal
let's talk about your most important
fundamental needs let's go right back to
psychology 101 maslow's hierarchy of
needs
uh you need food or else you die
so when you need food what is the signal
that your body sends you hunger when you
need water what is the signal
when you need um a air
yeah you're catching your breath when
you need rest what do you feel that's
right when you need connection what do
you feel lonely
human beings are designed to grow
when you stop growing what do you feel
stuck yeah
i was gonna say stagnant but i guess
stuck is you know we're stagnant yeah
we're still
trapped i guess as young yeah
feeling stuck is a signal that you've
stopped growing
that's it
and when most people feel stuck
since
they don't understand that it's tied to
a fundamental need for growth
we believe it's an existential crisis
and we blow up our lives
for most human beings what actually will
get you feeling like you're not stuck
is having something in the future that
you're looking forward to
or
taking a class where you're learning
something
or changing a routine
so that you try a new class at the gym
learning anything gets you back in touch
with a fundamental need it makes you
start to feel like things are moving and
from that place of feeling a little bit
more empowered
you'll be able to make better decisions
about what big things need to change in
your life
and is that you would also describe that
as a moment where your life has like an
absence of purpose
i think about i think about
various examples olympians that come
back from the olympics and they
they're like 80 chance of depression
after they've you know
and then i think about people who have
yeah lost purpose in their lives for
whatever reason been fired from their
jobs or whatever all people that are in
jobs that are
you know absent of purpose completely
that feeling of being stuck and
and then you said we talked also about
the importance of goals and ambitions
going forward when humans don't have
that forward ambition or that thing to
look forward to in the future
and their current situation lacks
purpose
they become very um
psychologically
disorientated mm-hmm the way i describe
it
um i act i have a different take on
purpose
um
i think everybody's purpose is exactly
the same
what is that
i think your purpose
is to share your true self
to be fully seen
and for the olympian when you are
training and you're in that arena
that is an experience of being seen
and for most people that are lacking
purpose they feel profoundly invisible
and
being seen
fundamentally comes back to whether or
not you even see yourself
and when you start to feel empowered and
you start to see yourself and meet you
where you are
what happens is
every day that you're able to stand with
yourself to accept where you are to give
yourself the compassion
to
give yourself the support and the love
and the
respect and the worthiness that you
deserve you're going to go out into the
world and share more of yourself
that olympic athlete is sharing
more of themselves
and so i think our purpose
in life is to
come back home to ourselves
to reconnect with ourselves
and to empower ourselves
to go back out into the world and share
our stories and share our experiences
and share our full selves with the rest
of the world
from a prehistoric standpoint let's say
you know because i always try and like
check things against the caveman of my
you know my ancestral
beings the the idea of being seen when i
was you know my ancestors 10 000 years
ago what kind of role does that play in
from a survival perspective well i i
mean i'm freestyling here so okay my
suspicion is
if you were not within your mom's eye
view
your ass was gonna get eaten
and so i think that uh you know if you
wandered off as a kid you were in danger
if you weren't hunting with the pack you
were in danger
and so being seen means safety and
that's why when you look at
psychological safety there are three
fundamental needs the need to be seen
the need to be heard
and they need to be celebrated
for the unique person that you are
those are your three
fundamental emotional needs when it
comes to feeling safe and whole as a
human being
and most people's experience by the time
they are done with childhood as they
feel invisible
they feel like nobody gets them
and they feel completely disconnected
and unloved or not celebrated
a ton of sense
yeah so i did okay on that answer yeah
it's a really really remarkable
refraining we have a new tradition on
the diary of a ceo which is in the diary
the famous diary of a ceo the previous
guest always writes a question for the
next guest that's coming and they don't
know who they are okay and these guests
they're so diverse it's always so
fascinating and they never know who
they're writing it for which is also
interesting the previous guest wrote
what is the one regret you have
if you have any at all
um
it's a it's a tricky question because
i'm one of these people that doesn't
want to go back and change anything i
think everybody is according to the
science we had a mogada sit here from
google he talked about the eraser test
he said even people that have gone
through profound trauma when asked the
question if they were to raise the
trauma
99 plus percent said no
because of the domino effect you don't
know you know it's an interesting one
yeah um you know like any behavior that
hurt somebody else
you know anything that i did whether it
was light or cheating or you know just
being an [ __ ]
when i was just trying to survive that
unintentionally hurt somebody else
yeah i wish that that wasn't part of my
story
um but
you know i wouldn't i wouldn't
understand
at a profound level
that
really well-meaning good people do
really shitty things when they feel
shitty about themselves
and you know if i hadn't done shitty
things when i felt shitty about myself
i
wouldn't
fully
believe that
and you might do that again i guess had
you not done it once yeah
yeah or twice or three times or four
times like first you gotta wake up you
know and then there's all the things
that i did that i don't realize hurt
somebody else
but you know i know
in my heart
that i was still a good person
i was just in a really bad place
which is you know why you do bad things
your relationship with yourself is the
foundation for everything in life
and if you believe you're a bad person
you will tend to do bad things
and the opposite is also true
if you believe that you are a good
person who is worthy of good things you
tend to do good things
unbelievably true
my last question for you is one that i
tend to always ask people i meet that i
find uh to be incredibly wise
and very good at helping others i mean
you help hundreds of millions of people
um combined um
which is
do you still struggle with
all of the [ __ ] you talk about oh my god
like yes
that's why i'm so [ __ ] relatable i do
not have this stuff figured out
i am shoulder to shoulder with everybody
um
whether it's issues going on with one of
my kids issues going on with one of me
you know with look you know just the
other night uh the
i mean i'm this is what happened i
self-published the audiobook
okay and um which is amazing because i'm
a smart [ __ ] i own my rights and
you should to this book no this one i
did a joint venture on the publishing
but i own all of the audio amazing and
um because the five-second rule is
self-published and it's the number one
selling self-published audiobook in the
history of audiobooks the book is
self-published
and um which is why i need to get into
nfts because my i don't like it when
somebody else has control i as an artist
want to own what i do as a businesswoman
nothing pisses me off more than getting
into a dumb deal
and then i resent the people that i'm in
the deal with because i didn't negotiate
properly and if you believe in what
you're doing you better own your work
you better understand the long tail
payoff of your work because nobody will
market your work better than you and you
will be profoundly pissed off when
somebody else is making their money
a hundred years from now and for every
author that's that's listening make sure
you look at amazon
because the uh
relatives of uh what's his face who
wrote the seven habits of highly
effective whatever they're the ones
collecting checks on that because that
book is still hitting so you want to be
like mariah carey she laughs all the way
to the bank whenever christmas rolls
around because of that song
and so you know i uh self-publish the
audiobook i have a tremendous
partnership with audible
where we create a lot of original
content for them behind their paywall
and i self-published this book and we
destroyed it in sales the month of
october the number one selling audiobook
period hands down of any book that was
published period ap reported it
everybody reported it and then the new
york times comes out
um in november and they uh rank the top
10 audiobooks
of the month of october
and they deliberately
left me off
and when that happened
i
punched the wall
i drank a gin martini
i lit up a joint
i called a couple friends and bitched
and i immediately got triggered because
i went right back
to the experience of being a ninth
grader on the tennis team
and having the seniors throw a party and
i was the only ninth grader who wasn't
involved
and so it triggered a very old pattern
that i thought i had [ __ ] gotten rid
of which is i'm an outsider
nobody likes me
i'm always having to sneak in
why am i never invited why am i not part
of the cool kids why am i not you know
like it's that old stupid-ass story that
got triggered
and so of course this [ __ ] happens it
happens all the time
and i just happen to talk about it
because i don't like feeling these
things and i find that just trying to
shove it down
makes the next time it happens get even
bigger
and so i share this stuff because i
think holding it in
is what's creating
a lot of anxiety and
regret and upset and stuckness for
people we are all so
the same
and the more that you know i kind of
share the ups and downs i think the more
people listen
to the things that are working and try
them out and tweak them for their own
life and look if i can save anybody the
heartache and the headaches that cause
myself
that's a life well lived
you know if i can laugh at myself along
the way if i can punch a wall and drink
a gin martini and then share with you
like okay this and then get out because
how i got out of that
because i could have been in that cycle
the old male would have been there for a
month
everybody's out to get me i never get
recognized why even bother it doesn't
matter
and
it allows me to share in real time
that i feel all the [ __ ]
but i don't like to stay there and this
is not toxic positivity
it is important
when you're disappointed to allow
yourself to feel disappointed
it is important when you lose something
to give yourself the grace to grieve for
as long as you need to it is important
to have a good cry to have a good scream
to draw it's important to feel the highs
and the lows you're meant to feel it all
but you can
shorten
the length of time
you stay down
and what always helps me it's something
that you know i i developed when the
high five the five second rule launch
was coming off the rails
as i just kept saying what i what i've
said
a couple times during this i i say to
myself
i refuse to believe
that if i'm a good person
and that if i'm working hard
i refuse to believe that this doesn't
work out
i refuse to believe that i'm not going
to be okay like i know
that this moment's gonna pass and i know
that i will look back on this moment
five years from now and i'll see exactly
what i was meant to learn
and what i was meant to learn i already
know
is that i have got to once and for all
stop looking for validation in old
institutions
if i truly want to be an artist on my
own terms
don't even pay attention to that [ __ ]
because it doesn't matter in the world
that we're living in now it doesn't
matter if you really want to make impact
because the person that's struggling is
the person that you want to reach
not the person that's deciding
who gets on some stupid list that's
printed in a paper
and
redirecting your focus to what actually
matters
and the fact that you believe in your
heart that you got the mindset you got
the work ethic you got the ability to
figure this [ __ ] out and to keep going
and that eventually if you do
what's meant for you is going to find
you you will be rewarded for all this
in the way that you're meant to be
rewarded
that's amazing it's an amazing feeling
because you can pick yourself up no
matter what happens
well thank god you do share it because
you know
you're a very special human being and
there's very few in the world that have
the the genius of
the skill stack where it's kind of how i
see it that you have where they're able
to go through things in life analyze
them understand them from a
psychological a scientific perspective
from a sort of intrinsic internal
perspective and then
be a masterful orator in sharing that in
a relatable honest way that helps others
to change their lives and
find uh find the piece they're looking
for find the outcomes they're searching
for there's very few that can do that
with such genius so that's a that's a
beautiful compliment and thank you for
saying that i really appreciate it and i
can hear it
for the first time in my life i can hear
it
and you've also
given me this like extraordinary insight
that i just got
um
so you asked me in the beginning
kind of
what is it that that created all of this
insight or this drive to figure it out
i think i just figured it out
you you just [ __ ] did it i just
figured it out
i spent
so long
being dysregulated
having a nervous system that was
constantly
on edge like what it felt like to be me
any moment in my life whether it was
sitting in a classroom or i was sitting
at that law firm bait stamping or i'm
sitting
as a young mom with postpartum
depression or i'm sitting in yet another
job i don't like
is it felt like
being in a car
at a stoplight that had a green signal
and the emergency brake was on and the
gas was floored and i was going nowhere
like just the engine revved and the
sense that i needed to go but not being
able to go
and
when i finally started
to get control of my own thinking
when i finally started to understand
anxiety
and how to quiet it in my mind and then
how to quiet it my body
when i finally got serious about
understanding trauma
and
healing
it in my nervous system first
through emdr through therapy through
guided mdma sessions
i finally had the experience
of being in my body
and being safe and being okay
and i hadn't had that in a really long
time
and um
i'm so
aware
of when i'm not in my body now i'm so
aware of when my nervous system starts
to go on edge
that my tolerance for staying there is
zero
because i live for far too long
feeling
on edge anxious dysregulated
self-loathing
that when i dip into that space and
everybody you dip into that space
once a day if not like i used to live
there
and so when i
start to dip into that dysregulated
anxious on-edge intense space
it's like
get this out of my body we got to get
back into my new default which is
grounded
centered
in control of what i'm thinking what i'm
going to do next
and it's a fluid situation
but you just gave me the insight as to
why it's so quick for me now
because i've made a commitment to myself
that after spending 30 years that way
40 almost
that i don't want to
live
another year that way another week that
way another full day that way
now do i have things that happen in my
life
that are
tough that that put me into a mode where
i'm anxious and on edge and of course
do i disassociate when i get really
awful of course
but i now have the tools
to bring myself back into my body
to give myself the encouragement the
assurance the support that i need
so that i can face whatever is happening
and know that i'm not only gonna be okay
i'm actually gonna be
awesome
eventually
that's beautiful
and um yeah i've got a little bit
emotional there too i am
i'd also assert that you figured that
out
um
and you're also helping a lot of other
people figure that out in themselves
which is
a remarkable i mean it's the highest
service i think any one human being
could do for society is to do what
you're doing at the moment
and yeah i you know if only there were
more forces in the world like you i
really i was thinking as you were
speaking i was thinking this
this woman really is a force in the
world and
nothing can stop you i really believe
that i was thinking nothing is you've
got too much
too strong too much too much intrinsic
drive that's coming from a lot of the
sort of traumas and experiences you've
described nothing can stop you no
inclusion on any list is going to stop
you probably only add to the to the the
coal fire inside of yourself
that's uh everything better just get out
the way thank you so much for the time
the honesty the openness the inspiration
for many a year i've seen you going way
back in to the viral video days on
facebook where you'd come up all the
time in my feed and i'd say who's this
person and what's this thing she's
talking about jumping out of bed and
isaac [ __ ] you know and then i was
trying you know trying it myself and it
was working for me so it's such a huge
honor and that's what i use sparingly
but in this case it's perfectly adequate
to sit here with you and to
spend some time with you and it's time i
won't forget so thank you
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you